what's been the biggest change since
you've been in the movie nothing ready
I'm so humiliated you
hello I'm Rhonda from Davis I play Jojo
rabbit and this is my fresh burst sounds
really Hollywood Mike is great I mean
he's got such a unique and personal
human that can relate to people people
used to say a lot of nasty things about
me oh look at that psycho he's gonna get
us all killed
he told me an answer so would you like
working with the best I've already said
I can I of course you can Scott was
amazing she can't she really did
transform my acting and because she's a
mother and she thought she was also a
child actress but she also understood
like the pressure and kind of the
feeling of being new she really helped
me probably already Sean know there was
one scene where all the actors were
mostly in it and that's actually that
David my brothers were there as extras
and there's a bear in the scene where
sound goes is there any judge for JJ to
do in forever ago she can walk the
clothes and that's a bit was my
brother's robes they were made anyway I
really want to work with Steven
Spielberg I don't know Bernie Brad Pitt
I can't I didn't look at Christian Bale
I like how he picks things wisely and he
only does things and kind of loves
[Music]
I understand you about all the actors
now of how I'm gonna really bug them I
find a way to talk to I pretend to be
like a waiter maybe one month I guess
I'm really lonely I'd already have any
friends separably my mother I had cheese
toasties and had a really bad dog yeah
well I tried to any I try to steal the
costumes but not this Nazi ones door mmm
I like stand by me there's kind of the
film that kind of want made me want to
act tiger 19 that sounds really cliche
[Music]
[Music]